what is logic I'll admit I will have
difficulty finding a straightforward way
of defining what logic is that will
satisfy everyone who uses it and
everybody who studies it but if you
weren't watching this video with me
asking that question right now
you'd probably head over to your
favorite know-it-all site you know the
one I'm talking about and it would tell
you that logic deals with valid
reasoning perhaps we could call it
structured thought maybe even well
structured thought I'll return to that
difference between reasoning and
reasoning well since that split does
come up in the historical back in the
forth dialogue on how to conceptualize
and understand logic but first let's
travel back to but one of the ancient
peoples who started to talk about logic
explicitly and use it to hone their
language and their arguments in ancient
Greece there lived a talkative and
thoughtful fellow who was socially
awkward enough that he failed to respect
conversational boundaries yet smart
enough then he knew how to call people
out on their foolishness this is of
course Socrates who actually didn't
claim he was so smart he went around
asking folks about presumably basic
topics like courage and self-control
claiming that he didn't really
understand these himself he asked
apparent experts to walk him through the
details so that he could come to
understand them at least a little bit
but as Plato tells it these initially
light conversations go from bad to worse
as the experts can't manage to give
Socrates a solid case for their own
perspectives on these topics in fact
they're routinely forced to admit that
they don't really know what they're
talking about but more than an ancient
tale of intellectual one-upmanship this
is among history's most iconic
demonstrations of logic in action
in a logical nutshell attempting to
define words and sentences meaningfully
and precisely structuring sentences into
an argument and checking to make sure
that that argument and those meanings
produce a coherent line of reasoning
that has a shot at drawing a true
conclusion like other figures in other
ancient societies Socrates shows us that
we can be thoughtful and precise in a
way that allows us to build a solid
argument and come to a specific
conclusion but there's a catch
the cost is because our thoughts are
explicit and not vague our argument can
be evaluated and corrected just as
precisely and we can be shown where
we're wrong on the other hand our
thoughts can remain vague and we can
remain free of any need to argue for our
point but then we have no reason to
think the right so it's shallow of us to
hold that a certain precise conclusion
is true this was the mistake of the
friends Socrates like to chat with they
assumed they had something figured out
but had never really thought about it
logically Aristotle cooked this way of
thinking under his scrutiny as best he
could see he could reduce logical
thinking to a basic set of structures
the basic structure of an argument was
for Aristotle the syllogism and it runs
something like this if a is B and if B
is C then a is C you can fill in a B and
C with your own favorite terms to see
what he was getting at here's my
preference if little Russian nesting
doll fits inside medium Russian nesting
doll and medium Russian nesting doll
fits inside big Russian nesting doll
then little Russian nesting doll fits
inside big Russian nesting doll
all men are mortal Socrates is a man so
Socrates is mortal
it may seem basic but in all syllogisms
we can use to supporting pieces of
information to draw a novel conclusion
that's not in that information already
this conclusion gets called an inference
oK we've used Socrates to look at logic
as a way of tightening up our
understanding of the topic the contents
of our reasoning and we've used
Aristotle to view logic as a way of
structuring thoughts regardless of their
contents the form of our reasoning that
second part of logic called formal logic
has done a lot to shape the makeup of
logic over the centuries by thinking
abstractly with variables and operators
to connect them magicians have
contributed to developments in
mathematics computer science and many
other endeavors rewind to that syllogism
stuff logically this structure is
considered valid that should mean it
always works right not so fast
look look we can fill it in with some
strange stuff the conclusion doesn't
actually have to be true for us to call
this structure logical valid logic gives
us true conclusions if we have true
information to begin with verifying the
accuracy of your content means while
doing your homework on whatever it is
you're arguing about we have so many
disciplines that study specific topics
rigorously and in detail meteorologists
aren't stuck imagining the reasonable
possible conclusions they can come to
about the weather they can use logic to
come to specific conclusions backed by
their observations and historians don't
just think about logically possible
sequences of events in the past but
argue for specific chronologies based on
their studies it's still logic it's
still logical but the content is as
specialized as the tools and methods
used by the experts in these fields
if you've been paying attention as much
as I expect anyone to pay attention to
some video on the Internet you at least
get the logic has something to do with
how we think about stuff maybe you even
gathered that it has much more to do
with the thinking about part than the
stuff part way to keep up in all this
thinking does logic describe our thought
process like an objective observer might
or does it judge our reasoning telling
us how we ought to think like an
impassioned partisan would while some
hopefuls have seen logic as at least
potentially a kind of physics of thought
it's usually treated and defined more
like an ethics of thought it doesn't
dictate how we think only how we should
think if we want to reason well that
doesn't make logic subjective in the
sense of ultimately just up to anyone's
whims it just means that since we can be
logical or illogical in our thinking
we've got to work at it if we want to be
logical